- In this Opening Faculty Roundtable,
entitled "Race and the
Transformation of Disciplines,"
we are extremely fortunate to
have five terrific scholars
who will share their
perspectives on these issues.
Each will offer approximately five minutes
of opening comments,
which will be followed
by a brief intra-panel discussion,
and then we will have
the remainder of our time
to take your questions.
I'm going to now offer a
very brief introduction
to each of our speakers
in the order in which they will speak.
And you should know that in the chat,
we also have links to their full bios
if you are interested
in having that information at this point.
Our first speaker will be Rod Ferguson
who's a professor of women's
gender and sexuality studies
and American studies at Yale University.
Ferguson's research and teaching interests
include the politics of culture,
women of color feminism,
the study of race, critical
university studies,
queer social movements, and social theory.
Matthew Guterl is professor
of Africana Studies
and American Studies,
and the Chair of American
Studies at Brown.
He's a historian of race and nation
with a focus on the U.S., from
the Civil War to the present.
Marci Kwon is an assistant
professor of Art and Art History
at Stanford University.
Her research and teaching
interests include the intersection
of fine art and vernacular
practice, theories of modernism,
cultural exchange between
Asia and the Americas,
folk and self-taught art, and
issues of race and objecthood.
Noémie Ndiyae is an assistant
professor of English
at the University of Chicago.
Her research and teaching
explores the relationship
between theater understood
simultaneously as a medium,
a practice, an industry, an
institution, a social force,
and a vibrant malleable
set of literary forms,
and the social political
cultural struggles
of early modernity.
And finally, we will
hear from Teresa Montoya,
who is the Provost Postdoctoral Fellow,
and in 2022 will be an assistant
professor of anthropology
at the University of Chicago.
She's a social scientist and media maker
trained in socio-cultural anthropology,
critical indigenous
studies, and filmmaking.
Please join me in welcoming,
virtually, our panelists.
And we will now hear from
Rod Ferguson. Thank you.
- All right. Well, thanks so much.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I'm gonna set my watch for five minutes
so that I don't go over.
For me, the question
of the racial reckoning
with the disciplines
begins with the question of the
reorganization of knowledge,
one, and its relationship
to the cultivation
of underrepresented and
new communities of subjects
within the university,
within, and also outside
of the discipline.
And I'll say more about that a bit later.
But this was something
that was driven home for me
when I was a grad student at UC San Diego
being advised by George
Lipsetts and Lisa Lowe.
There was something about that moment
in which things clicked for me,
that the work that were doing
was not simply a textual exercise, right,
that it had institutional and
epistemological implications,
things were supposed to
shift, that the work, in fact,
the work that we were doing
in our dissertations, for the
professors, and their books,
it was to announce both epistemic ships
and also institutional shifts
within fields, on campuses,
in terms of faculty, and
also in terms of students.
And so, that was a
profound revelation for me,
that it wasn't simply a kind
of professional exercise,
the study of race and its
impact on the disciplines,
it wasn't simply a kind
of professional exercise
that was used to satisfy
certain benchmarks in terms of
the awarding of a PhD, or promotion,
that it was about reorganizing
the taken-for-granted knowledges
within certain fields,
introducing other forms of
knowledge within those fields,
and also making space for
underrepresented people,
new subjects, new communities,
who would also take up the
question or the act of reckoning,
and offer, really, new
kinds of innovations
at the level of scholarship.
There is a passage
in Jacques Derrida's the
"Eyes of the University"
that kind of summed it up for me.
I'd always had that sense, again,
from my time at UC San Diego,
the work that I was doing
with my colleagues there,
the advising that I was getting
from people like George and Lisa,
but it wasn't until I encountered
this passage from Derrida,
that I had language for the institutional
and social importance of
the work that we were doing.
And so, I'll just read a bit
from that passage, all right?
He says, "With students
in the research community
in every operation we pursue together,
a reading, an interpretation,
the construction of a theoretical model,
the rhetoric of an argumentation,
the treatment of historical material,
and even a mathematical formalization,
we posit or acknowledge that
an institutional concept
is at play, a type of contract signed,
an image of the ideal seminar constructed,
a socius implied, repeated, or displaced,
invented, transformed,
threatened, or destroyed.
An institution is not merely a few walls
or some outer structures
surrounding, protecting,
guaranteeing, or restricting
the freedom of our work,
it is also, and already,
the structure of our interpretation."
And so, part of what I
find so useful about that
is that it gets at the
immediacy of the reckoning,
that the reckoning happens at the moment
that we're thinking about
the book we're gonna write,
the course we're gonna teach,
how we frame those things,
and that in those very
immediate and small acts,
we're actually trying to
either repeat a discipline
or displace
disciplinary knowledge
in the name of alternative
forms of knowledge.
All right, so, I'll stop there. Thank you.
- I have spent much of the pandemic
thinking about a 40-year-old novel,
Octavia Butler's "Kindred",
and I wanna talk a little bit about it
before I share my thoughts
about the humanities.
Published in 1979, the
book tells the story
of a Black woman named Dana
who suddenly, inexplicably,
and repeatedly transported
back to the Antebellum South
to save her ancestor, a White
slave owner named Rufus.
Whenever Rufus' life is threatened,
Dana is yanked backwards in
time without warning or control.
Her reappearances,
though, keep Rufus alive
and, by extension, ensure
her very existence.
And by the novel's conclusion,
Dana is fundamentally changed
by this recursive experience,
leading us to wonder about
causality and inevitability.
The world around her notably remains
just as disturbingly uneven
as it was at the start.
But Dana is a hero for our pandemic.
Nonplussed by her time traveling,
she's practical and level-headed,
routinely confronts terror
with thoughtful planning.
After her first dislocation,
she returns home and has the forethought
to wisely assemble a bag
of necessary supplies,
tying them to her waist.
She brings maps and history books
from the present into the past,
along with knives and painkillers,
soap, toothpaste, and clothing.
Like the author who created
her, Dana is defined by lists
and is a champion of organized thinking
in the face of calamity.
This faith in relentless
practicality saves her life.
The knife she brings back in time,
the kind of weapon denied
to any enslaved person,
the kind of weapon she
knew she might need,
is what she uses to kill Rufus
in the novel's final pages.
I've shared "Kindred" more
times than I can count
in the last 12 months.
My deepest hope has been
that the students who are
now zooming into our meetups
from bedrooms, kitchen tables, and patios,
in almost every conceivable time zone
and who might feel displaced,
buffeted, and even scared,
can find, in Dana's steely determination,
a practical model for their
own everyday survival.
There's a valuable
lesson here for us, too,
as we ponder the relationship
between race and the humanities.
All of Dana's courage and imagination
inevitably leads her
right back to the present.
There is no other timeline
and no counterfactual reality.
Her movements back and forth
from the Antebellum South
to the modern present
change nothing in her world.
She gains memories, a measure of herself,
and a sober understanding
of the realities of slavery.
But she loses something, too.
After Rufus' death, she materializes back
in present day California,
her arm painfully adjoined
to the timbers and nails
and plaster of the house.
Its removal sets her free,
but leaves her without a limb.
"I really couldn't let her
come all the way back,"
Butler once explained to Randall Kenan.
"I couldn't let her
return to what she was.
I couldn't let her come back whole."
When I was first asked to consider
the idea of a racial reckoning,
I returned once more to "Kindred".
A reckoning, I know, is a
dramatic settlement of debts.
It can be a jarring event, a
disruptive, painful occurrence.
It should cost.
And who should bear that cost?
I thought of field-locked
history departments
and English departments
unable to truly center
racial justice in their work
because of an old-fashioned commitment
to geographic or temporal divisions
that date back to Jim Crow,
to White supremacy, or to empire.
I thought of entire disciplines,
classics, for instance,
or medieval studies,
where the labor of decades
is now the foundation
stone of White supremacy.
I thought of the small inter-disciplines,
many of them zeroed in on race,
all of them starved for resources
compared to their larger
peers, and overdetermined
as the place where race
happens, or is, or will be.
I thought of budget models like RCM,
which valorize student credit hours
over righteousness or social importance.
I thought of all of this and so much more
and asked, "Exactly what sort
of reckoning should there be?"
Such questions come to me,
even as I am overwhelmed,
joyfully and ecstatically,
by the volume of work
in the humanities on race.
I am drowning in books, in
podcasts, in graphic novels,
in think pieces, in documentaries,
and in Twitter threads,
surrounded, at home and at
work, by disorganized piles,
alphabetical piles, thematic
piles, and color-coded piles.
Every single one of them,
evidence that the dam has burst,
that we are, in some very perverse way,
fortunate to be writing and
thinking through all of this,
our own dystopia together,
with such a vast and extraordinary
assemblage of people,
authors of some of the
best work ever conceived.
What would it mean to
center this everywhere?
How could that happen?
And what would that cost the humanities?
To paraphrase Butler,
"After a true reckoning
with our past and present,
would we want to bring the
university all the way back?"
The humanities will
someday have a reckoning,
and that reckoning will, I
think, tear these places apart
and leave them conceptually
burning and broken.
There's some promise in
our perspective losses,
in what parts of these
places might be cut off.
And we in the Zoom should
all be planning for it
with knapsacks tied to our waists
filled with old maps and history books,
painkillers and knives,
and soaps, and toothpastes.
Thank you.
- Hi, everyone.
Thank you for having me here today.
Can't do anything without images, so.
So, this year, the Cantor Arts Center,
which is the University Art
Museum here at Stanford,
launched the Asian-American
Art Initiative.
Co-directed by myself and Elisa Alexander,
Curator of American Art,
the Initiative is dedicated to
the collection, preservation,
research, and exhibition
of work by Asian-American
and diaspora artists,
who, with the exception of a
handful of canonical figures,
remain almost entirely
unknown in art history.
The dearth of interest and support
for Asian-American
artists within art history
stands in direct contrast
to the historical importance
of the arts to Asian-Americans.
While researching the 2009 survey tax
to "Asian American Art:
A History, 1850-1970",
Mark Dean Johnson, who
actually worked on this project
as a fellow at CSRE, and
Stanford historian, Gordon Chang,
identified over 1,000
artists of Asian descent
working in California alone
during this chronological stand.
which is, again, an 1850 to 1970.
So, this number is staggering,
indicating not only
the significance of art
and art-making for Asian-Americans,
but also the enormous volume of work
that remains to be studied and
has likely been lost to time.
And what you see on
your screen is actually,
they're photographs
from May's Photo Studio,
which was a Chinese-run photography studio
in San Francisco Chinatown,
akin to James Van Der Zee,
photographing the community.
And these works were saved, actually,
from a dumpster in the 1970s,
by the artist Wiley Wong.
What you see here are ma-rk-ets,
photographs that were
actually pieced together
in the dark room, kind of uniting
families that were divided
by American legal, like,
exclusionary immigration policy.
So, we launched this
year with a collection
that includes 151 historical works
from the estate of a private collector,
which were being held in a
storage locker in San Rafael,
which you see on the screen on the left.
We also received donations
from foundations of artists,
such as Martin Wong and Bernie Spain,
whose work you see on the right.
It's actually covered in plastic,
which is why it looks like that.
On the left is a painting
from the Brown collection
by the first documented
Japanese-American painter
in the United States.
And we also acquired an
untitled wall of masks
by the artist, Ruth Asawa,
who cast them from the faces
of visitors to her home.
And they include people
like Anna Deavere Smith.
We have also made it a priority
to ensure that we preserve
archival material from these artists.
So, Asian-American studies
has helped me think through
the ethical dimensions of this project.
It is not lost on me that part
of our history's conservatism
has to do with its emphasis
on physical objects,
objects that are bought and sold,
making it more obviously
entangled with market forces
than other academic disciplines.
This has also made art history
especially reliant on
institutions, such as museums,
to undertake the extensive
and expensive conservation,
preservation, and
display, of works of art.
And finally, there's the problem
with the way that race
and identity discourse
are mobilized by institutions
as a means to manage descent,
an issue that Rod's work,
as well as Riley's edited
volume with hin-tai-gap
has helped me think through.
So, we've tried to navigate
these ethical challenges in multiple ways.
In our discussions of the
Asian-American Art Initiative,
we always begin with the
fact that Stanford is itself
unthinkable without the entwined histories
of Chinese immigrant labor
imperialist expansion
and capitalism, as
ma-noo-koo-roo-kar has shown.
And in fact, The Golden Last Spike
and the silver mallet used
to hammer it into place,
the joining of the
transcontinental railroad,
are at the Cantor Arts Center.
Recent archeological
work has also revealed
that even the palm trees on Palm Drive
were planted by Chinese laborers.
So, another goal of our work
is to show how historical research
and deep formal engagement
with works of art
breaks rather than reinforces
a monolithic idea of Asian-America
as a bounded identity forum,
as well as its assumptions
of a single-nation state.
And rather than keeping our
work in the feedback loop
with academia, the
museum, and the art world,
we're trying to make sure that
we engage local communities
in part, through education
and public programming,
and most importantly,
we know that our efforts
cannot benefit just the
community of Asian-Americans,
but all racialized groups
whose histories and lives
are entangled with ours.
And I wanna acknowledge
that CSRE and Jen Brody,
in particular, have been
unfailingly supportive
of these efforts.
So, still I must admit that
I have serious reservations
about how our work will be used,
something that keeps me up at night.
Museums are, of course,
colonial institutions
built on the hoarding of
property and increasingly reliant
on the commodification of people of color.
All I can say is that I believe
the work of these artists
have many things to teach
us about the structures
that have attempted to
circumscribe their existence.
I can only imagine the things
they will teach us about,
for example, racial
capitalism and aesthetics,
the way, quote, art has
been historically tethered
to the idea of the human
and hierarchies of tastes and value.
Our history should be the
study of all of these things.
But also, as an Anne Cheng has pointed out
more than 20 years ago,
and continues to remind us,
in the United States, a person of color
is seen as worthy of attention
only when they have suffered visible harm.
While Asian-American artists
have never been outside of history,
they invite us to think and feel
in ways that perhaps sidestep
this obsession with injury.
Their work shows us the
multiple and complex ways
Asian-Americans have lived, worked,
created, desired, and imagined,
in relation to a world that
seeks evermore devious ways
to homogenize and devalue them.
Thank you.
- Thank you. Hello, everybody.
I am thrilled to be here in the
presence of such brilliance.
And I'm really excited to
learn from everybody today.
I hope to contribute something
to this ongoing conversation
by telling you a little bit
about the current state of my field,
early modern critical race studies,
and telling you about its current states
through the lens of our key
concept, racial reckonings.
So, what do we do?
Early modern critical race scholars
examine the deployment
of racial formations
in periods prior to the development
of so-called scientific racism
in the 18th century, starting in 1492.
And we do so in various cultural domains,
such as literature, performance, religion,
visual culture, material
culture, and more.
The word reckoning, as
was pointed out earlier,
is etymologically embedded
in practices of accounting,
it's about numbers.
It's about counting, putting
an order, calculating,
and including in that count,
what must be included and accounted for.
The pioneers of my field
had to counter the convenient assumption
that there were no BIPOC
people in early modern Europe,
or differently put,
that Shakespeare had
never seen a Black person
when he wrote "Othello", quote unquote.
In order to make a case
where the importance of racial thinking
in early modern Europe, we
are indebted to the subfield
of presence studies best illustrated
by the painstaking work
of the late Imtiaz Habib
and his marvelous "Black
Lives in the English Archives"
for some serious reckoning.
For the field can only grow, I'm sorry,
for the field to grow,
reckoning in the
accountant's sense applied,
and still applies,
not only to the archives,
but to those who read them.
It has thus been an
imperative in our field
to reckon with the dismal
numbers of BIPOC scholars
in early modern studies.
The most English curricula, as you know,
have a Shakespeare requirement.
But to the best of my knowledge,
there are only, currently,
less than 20 tenure-track faculty members
who identify as Black
Shakespeare professors
in the U.S. at the moment.
We also have had, and still have,
to start building diverse pipelines,
which is an ongoing struggle
because BIPOC students
are conditioned, or maybe disciplined,
from high school onwards
into thinking of the pre-modern periods
as irrelevant to their concerns.
Of course, that is a misconception.
We know that Stuart Hall
originally wanted to be a medievalist
and that Sylvia Wynter, for instance,
was primarily trained as a specialist
of early modern Spanish drama.
In short, racial reckonings in my field
have been about changing both
the objects that we study
and the demographics of
scholars who study them.
But, of course, a disciplinary
field can only be transformed
if its theoretical frameworks,
tools, and questions,
are transformed as well.
Early modern critical race
studies emerged historically
in the mid '90s when
scholars like Kim F. Hall
brought theoretical frameworks
drawn from Black feminism
and critical race theory to
bear, on early modern materials,
and to make early modern
studies accountable.
Ania Loomba, around the
same time, did the same
with frameworks drawn from
post-colonial feminism.
The second wave of scholarship on race
in the early modern period
started in the first
decade of the 21st century,
and we are now in the third, or fourth,
depending on how you count,
wave of scholarship in the field.
Yet valid concerns have been expressed
by field founders, Kim F. Hall,
and Peter Erickson, in 2016,
in the 2016 special issue
of "Shakespeare Quarterly",
focused on race.
And they alerted us, in that issue,
to the risks of dispersion,
to the very real risks that the field,
even as it starts receiving
institutional recognition
in various forms, might
lose its political impetus
and its original concern
with racial justice.
To honor and to act
upon the activist drive
that founded the field,
a research collaborative,
such as RaceB4Race,
which was founded by Ayana Thompson,
and U Chicago is a partner
institution of RaceB4Race,
that collaborative has, for
the last couple of years,
advocated, in various
forums, for the centrality
of critical race theory to the field.
If you're curious to hear more,
I encourage you to check
the webpage of RaceB4Race.
Our next symposium, I'm sorry
I have to make a quick plug,
our next symposium focused on politics,
that's the theme, with
a keynote by Ibram Kendi
opens this coming Tuesday.
But to return to my point,
racial reckoning is about
political accountability,
which must be intentionally cultivated
at all times, in my field.
We were asked to think about the ways
in which we center racial
justice in our work,
and it is perhaps for research,
the research part of our work,
that the question is most urgent.
An example might be useful at this point.
In my most recent article,
making my work politically
accountable to the present
has meant that when I
started noticing slippages
in 17th-century plays
which depict and label the same characters
alternately as Blackamoors
and Romani gypsies,
I had to think about those
early modern slippages
through the lens of the
many instances today
when scholars working
in the fledgling field
of critical Romani studies,
invoke paradigms from Black studies
in pursuit of shared liberation.
This led me to read the
early modern archive
as providing an ethically
binding genealogy
for those critical alliances,
which are reconstituting now.
Methodologically speaking,
doing such work requires
never forgetting about the
present as you analyze the past,
developing some sort of double vision,
moving to and fro between
historization and theorization.
Racial reckonings also
transform disciplinary affects.
To do this work, you have to keep in mind
that the stakes of the work,
as Rod was pointing out earlier,
the stakes of the work, which are surreal,
they outweigh the playful dimension
of aesthetic exploration,
which is one of the main
appeals of literary studies.
And you have to pay close attention
to the ways in which paranoid
or reparative leanings
might inform your own
scholarship and its reception,
because those matter.
I will close by saying that
working with theoretical
bodies of knowledge
produced in other disciplines,
such as critical race theory,
Black studies, sociology,
and in my case, performance
studies and dance studies,
is a move that is welcome
in English studies.
English has historically been
characterized as a discipline
by anti-disciplinary drives,
at least in the departments
where I have had the good fortune to work,
and in very recent years.
Thus, I have personally found English
to be a good non-disciplining
discipline to operate from.
But I do think that
the future developments
of early modern critical race studies
require expanding in transnational
and multi-linguistic directions,
so, taking the project in a
com-plar direction, if you will,
because the invention of
Whiteness in the pre-modern era
was a transnational endeavor.
So, such extension is in
tune with the transnational
and diasporic dynamics
that have always been at
the core of Black studies.
And I believe that the study
of race along those lines
can help early modern English studies
move past the Anglocentrism
that has, for so long,
limited their purview and potential.
Thank you.
- (speaks in foreign language)
Thank you to the organizers
for convening this important dialogue.
For my indigenous colleagues
who are tuning in,
I will also introduce
myself as a Dene woman.
(speaks in foreign
language) Teresa Montoya
(speaks in foreign language)
My so-called interracial heritage
is revealed in the introduction
of my four Dene clans.
My mother's clan is followed
by my non-Native father
of Mexican and German-American ancestry.
But unlike Euro-American categories
of racial and ethnic classification,
Dene and indigenous epistemologies
are shared in order to find connection,
identify a means of relation,
and also responsibility to each other,
rather than social difference.
It is perhaps of this knowledge
so ingrained in my identity formation,
living in, and between
my mother's birth home
on Navajo Nation, and the
offers of Asian places
that she carried me,
that curiosities of my own
racialized difference took hold.
For many BIPOC scholars, our
histories and vulnerabilities
are what drives the work that we do
and also what makes it so
difficult because our bodies,
our skin, and our
histories, can also become
uncomfortable points of
critical interrogation.
Increasingly, I'm finding strength
in this radical vulnerability
as a way of reckoning my own place
in the trajectory of historically
White academic spaces
the role that our disciplinary
founders, in quotes here,
have played in shaping these discourses
and how this knowledge can
be employed in our pedagogy,
activism, and public engagements,
to confront structures of
racism, White supremacy,
and settler-colonial violence.
So, I present this intimate portrait
as an invitation for us to
explore the differential ways
that race is invoked in
discussions of Blackness
in indigeneity, in Asian studies,
and what connections might be forged
between our overlapping
and unique struggles.
These concerns, of course,
are by no means new.
In the discipline of anthropology,
in which I was trained, for instance,
scholars like Lee Baker have interrogated
how categories of culture were deployed
to study the so-called
disappearing Indians
by early American ethnologists
while categories of race for
use by early sociologists
to study African-Americans.
The problems of classification
and differentiation
are not only a disciplinary one,
but also a trademark of
colonial and imperial power.
Consider now the category of Indian,
the fallacy of the title
references a gross navigational error
by the mass murder of
Christopher Columbus.
As documented in his own journals,
the transatlantic voyage
of Columbus set in motion
centuries of European
colonization in the Americas.
Under his leadership,
the indigenous population of Hispaniola,
now Haiti and the Dominican Republic,
estimated between 500,000
to 1 million people in 1492,
plummeted to 60,000 within
a single generation.
Following this violent encounter,
European philosophers and
theologians began to consider
the morality and humanity
of the Native inhabitants
that they, quote, discovered.
Did they have souls?
Did they possess reason?
Could they be governed?
Contrary to the assumption
that conquest was justified
through the construction
of radical alterity,
colonization under the Spanish empire,
legitimized through the Christian logic
of divine hierarchal power,
made the Indian into
irrational and legible subject
in order to be governable.
On the other hand, as argued by scholars,
such as Stuart Banner,
the British were less
concerned about soul matter
or capacity for rationality
within a humanistic tradition.
Rather, the colonization of North America
required an initial recognition
of indigenous property ownership.
To the extent that the
English wanted Indian land,
than they would have to purchase it.
The recognition of Native
property, it seems,
was only in the moment
in the sale transaction.
This larger notion of
political recognition
engaged by scholars,
such as Audra Simpson,
Glen Coulthard, Beth ko-ven-alee
and property, is central to
ongoing political debates
over indigenous sovereignty
and their right to existence
in settler-colonial states of Australia,
New Zealand, Canada, and
the United States today.
Therefore, to reckon with the violence
of racial classification
is also to confront the persistent
structures of Whiteness,
which, as Aboriginal scholar,
Eileen Warren Robertson,
argues, is rooted within
logics of possession,
whether it be owning property,
being property, or becoming property-less.
These ideas around property and possession
form the basis of a settler
and a White national identity,
an identity that many
Native scholars have argued
is also predicated on the
dispossession of indigenous land,
the dilution of indigenous
blood and identity
through blood quantum politics,
as critically explored by
Lakota scholar, Kim TallBear,
and Osage scholar, Jean Dennison,
and the erasure of limitations
of indigenous sovereignty
in federal Indian policy.
So, to bring us back to the
title of our panel today,
"Racial Reckonings", I'd like
for all of us to consider
the tangible ways we can build upon
existing race conversations
to imagine how we might
translate these disciplinary
and historical differences
into greater solidarity
around movements for reparations
and land acknowledgements
in our respective campuses.
This is, by no means, an
end goal, but rather one way
to demand a radically different
relationship of universities
with their histories and those they serve.
Thank you, and (speaks
in foreign language).
- Thank you, everyone.
Those were phenomenal opening comments
with so much depth and complexity.
Usually, I have lots
of synthetic questions.
I have a couple (laughs)
because I'm still digesting.
That was amazing.
I wanna open, if you don't mind,
with a very broad question
that I think most of you,
if not all of you, sort
of touched indirectly on
in your comments, at one point or another.
And so, let me ask the question
and then I'll see if I
can remind the audience
of a few of the examples
of when it came up.
So, my sort of broad
sort of intentionally a little
bit provocative question is,
do you think the disciplinary structures
that we are grappling with
are capable of being
a part of the transformations,
being a productive part
of the transformations
that your collective work
is speaking to, right?
That is to say, are they
going to be blown up?
Matt sort of has an image
that they're going to disintegrate,
I'm looking forward to seeing that.
Rod talked a bit about, right,
the ways in which there's an institutional
and epistemological challenge,
which implies, right,
that things are going to have
to be dramatically changed.
Marci's talking about the
role of this kind of the art,
and bringing these objects
into places that are colonial,
but also transforming that relationship,
as three quick examples.
But are these institutions
really capable of this?
I guess I wanna push a few of you,
if you're interested in taking
the challenge, to sort of
really explore that, right?
I mean, I understand what we're doing
in relation to these institutions,
but when we're in our relative cubbies,
it doesn't seem like a lot
of disruptions happening.
When we're together in a cohort,
there seems like a lot of
disruption of amazing scholars.
But there's a lot of
people doing this work
in the way that we would be challenged by.
So, I'm just throwing it open.
I don't know, anyone, I'm open to anyone.
I think I mentioned Marci, Matt, and Rod,
so, maybe one of you could start us off,
and then everyone is open to engage.
- [Rod] Okay, well maybe I'll go.
- Okay. Thanks, Rod.
- (laughs) Pleasure.
I think it's difficult for every field
within a university because,
especially the disciplines,
I mean, even the category, the discipline,
is in and of itself,
it means a resistance
to change, innovation,
shifts, blah, blah, blah.
And it's not as if the inner disciplines
are immune from that
because they're also
subject to those logics.
At the same time,
even with the problems of
the interdisciplinary fields,
I would put my money on
the inter-disciplines
over the disciplines in
terms of the kinds of changes
that you're talking about, right?
If you look at
where are the minoritized
faculty hired, located, students,
underrepresented students
in terms of majors, located,
it's in the inter-disciplines.
I mean, I'll never forget a conference,
or a symposium that I went to years ago,
I think like in 2011, at UCLA,
between the UCLA Center
for the Study of Women
and NYU's counterpart, they
had a joint conference.
And Kathleen McHugh, who was the Director
of the Center at UCLA, had a slide up
showing where all of the
underrepresented faculty were
in the University,
and they were all in
the inter-disciplines.
So, the question was, if we
took away the inter-disciplines,
what would then happen
to those faculty members?
They would be gone, okay?
That's one example.
If you think about another example,
I'm a bit biased here, but
I also think it's true,
the American Studies Association, right,
and all of the sort of
epistemic revolutions
that field has gone through,
from the immediate end of World War II
in terms of American studies
really being an alibi
for the U.S. during the Cold War period,
but also then being changed
by the social movements
around race and gender,
and then being changed again
by the critique of U.S.
empire and globalization,
thinking here of that "Cultures
of U.S. Imperialism" book
from Amy Kaplan and
Don P., that anthology,
but then changed again
in terms of post-nationalist
American studies,
then changing again because
of the work of scholars
in disability studies, in queer
studies, in trans studies,
and in Indigenous studies.
So, we can actually point to instances
in which the inter-disciplines have been
more ready to enact the kind of changes
that you're talking about.
There are still problems,
I don't wanna lose sight of that,
but in terms of the
kinds of transformations,
both epistemic and social,
the inter-disciplines will carry the day,
I mean, they carry that history.
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Okay, all right.
So, long live the inter-disciplines.
- Long live the inter-disciplines.
- Matt, did you wanna
jump in, or Marci, or?
- I'll buy Marci some time.
I think, Tricia, to answer
your question directly,
I think it's a question
of whether the disciplines should survive,
whether the humanities
should survive as they are
in order to center racial justice,
or just race in the humanities.
And I don't think they should,
I don't think they can.
I think this is the second paragraph
after Rod's paragraph,
about the value of the inter-disciplines,
is that the disciplines themselves
are inherently conservative and hegemonic,
and that we stand to have to
fight department by department,
field by field, sub field by sub field,
in order to advance interests,
to get one hire, one faculty
member, one course taught,
and that struggle will outlive us.
We can't win that struggle.
So, it is true that in some institutions,
so much of this is
university by university,
like, I'm thinking about
my own history department
at Rutgers, which I much belove,
but which centered Black women's history
from the moment I got there and
was utterly formative to me,
but most history departments, as you know,
even within the U.S.
field, have subdivisions
that mitigate and constrain any department
from actually hiring or focusing on race.
- Right, yeah, it's a
very effective mechanism,
that's what I'm really trying to get at,
is that despite these
incredible interventions, right,
there's been just a
capacity to reproduce itself
in all of its narrowness.
But let me let Marci jump in, Marci.
- Yeah, thank you.
So, yeah, sitting here trying
to think about your question,
the only word that was going
through my head was like,
"No," like,
they're not capable, museums
are not capable, art history,
for all the reasons we've
been kind of delineating.
And as I tried to kind of
point out in my presentation,
it's just like this paradox
that I have been grappling with
in doing this work
where it really started when
I was teaching this class
on Asian-American art when I
first got to Stanford in 2016,
and I just realized how much of this work
was in people's homes,
in their garages,
like, these are works
that have material lives,
they endure in time.
I mean, Ruth Asawa called those
masks moments of stop time,
which is, on one hand,
I think something that
makes them so powerful,
and on the other hand,
is what makes them fetish objects, right,
and people wanna desire them so much.
And so, like that contradiction
seems to me to be built
like, directly into the character
of an art object itself.
And, of course, there are
like kind of contemporary practices
that attempt to critique
and deconstruct this,
but like, we're talking about
an entire kind of history of work.
And so,
I think that for now,
all I've been trying to do is,
in some ways, tolerate that paradox,
and know that this work,
the Bernice Bing that I showed you,
part of the condition of taking it was,
it was damaged in a fire
and the museum has the
resources to restore it.
And she tried to,
it was important to her as from '65,
and she tried to restore it
at the end of her life before she passed.
And so, like,
those moments I know are important,
but ultimately, I think the accretion,
if we're really trying to move
towards like racial justice,
is that they will destroy the
institutions that they're in.
- Right. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is one of the tensions.
Okay, I have one more
and then I'm gonna move
to our audience questions.
I just wanna encourage
people who are listening
to place their questions in the Q&A,
and we'll do our best to get to them.
One more thing, and I'm
gonna ask Teresa and Noemie
to just sort of begin, but
everyone's welcome to jump in,
and that is, this really
interesting tension
between the expression
a number of you used,
the influence of racial analysis
to force a change in the objects,
and that by changing the objects,
we are in the process of doing
some kind of important
racially transformational work.
Noemie, you mentioned this.
Teresa, I think you said
something along these lines.
And by interesting contrast, I think, Rod,
you were the only one to talk
about sort of new subjects
in the university coming into place.
So, and then, of course, Matt,
the objects that Dana brings back, right,
are extremely important for her survival.
So, I'm interested in this
tension around objects,
the importance of using objects,
but, of course, the objectification,
the fact that racial
subjects are, in fact,
the original objects, and
what to do with that tension.
And just talk a little bit more about
what this changing of objects
means in the disciplines
and whether or not it must be accompanied
by a change in subject,
and how those things might fit together.
- Teresa, do you wanna go first?
I'm happy to go, if you prefer.
- Yeah, I guess I might come
back to this after you again.
As the sole social scientist here,
I might be coming at this
question a little bit differently.
Maybe I'll just answer
this by way of explaining
my own desire, impulse, to
even go into anthropology.
As many of you may know,
I mean, anthropology was a discipline
that relied extensively
upon the study of others,
of Native Americans, of our bones,
our literal bodies, right?
And this also fields, museum collections,
early ethnological collection.
So, my interest is really
around the material culture
and the actual objects, right?
So, my initial desire
to go into anthropology
was through museum anthropology.
I wanted to be in these museum spaces
to try to curate this history
in a more appropriate way,
in a way that was more respectful
to my ancestors and our relatives
that are literally still
in use museum collections.
And like all of you that
have expressed this caution
around the potential for
institutional change,
I felt that very strongly
actually with museums.
And it actually was part
of the reason why I've,
even though I continue to do museum work
and I continue to
guest-curate for exhibitions,
I still found potential
in education itself.
So, this is why I've
gone through this route
of doing research and education,
rather than going the route
of becoming a curator.
That being said,
there's still a lot to be
changed within anthropology.
At the University of Chicago,
I'm one of just a few Native faculty
who have ever existed, (chuckles)
and there is no existing
Native studies program.
When I was hired, and when I accepted,
it was on the condition
that there would be
this Native studies program information.
I know there's these
conversations happening
and there's definitely some movement,
but I know that this will take time,
institutional change takes time.
So, for myself, where I see
maybe the potential for change,
in what I think all of us
maybe should be pushing back against
across each of our disciplines,
is just the single author model.
Like, that's something
that has become increasingly
bothersome to me
that I didn't really question
at all as a graduate student.
And I've had these conversations
with a lot of other folks.
So, now that I'm in my post-doc,
I've found myself actually
increasingly collaborating
with people in other
disciplines, in the sciences,
in public health, or folks
who are working in hydrology,
like things I didn't
really imagine before,
but it was because the problems
that I'm confronting in my research,
I think, necessitates people who are doing
the like on-the-ground work,
and I can bring like a historical,
or a political sort of
analysis to that sort of work.
And I work on environmental contamination
and Indigenous sovereignty
in the Southwest.
So, those are kind of some of my concerns
that I've been struggling with
over the past year or two,
is I'm now charting this new
trajectory of my research
and, obviously, COVID has thrown
a lot of my previous plans ajar a bit.
But yeah, I would love to
hear from the rest of you
about what, not just
within our own disciplines
and departments, but the
larger structures of academia,
and how we can imagine change
or ways to push back on these structures
that have been confining to us.
- Yeah, so, I'm going to
answer your question, Tricia,
about subjects versus objects,
although there is no versus really,
but just, I wanted to go back first
to the question about disciplines,
can the disciplines
help, are they capable?
I will say that I personally
have very little interest
in disciplinarity, or disciplines,
or the survival or
capabilities of discipline.
I got my PhD in theater
from a Department of English
and Comparative Literature,
and it was working mostly
on Spanish and French lit
within that structure.
So, I think it's
particularly the case for me,
but it's the case of all of us
that we are not working in a discipline,
we're all working within a Venn diagram
of multiple disciplines, right?
And so, I would just say
that I am very opportunistic about this.
I don't have faith in the disciplines,
but I also am very willing to
mobilize them strategically.
And for instance,
right now I'm teaching a course
called Black Shakespeare,
and I am very willing, very ready,
to harness all the disciplinary
affordances of English,
studying the hyper-canonical
figure of Shakespeare
if it allows me to get students
to think about race critically,
to bring into the room all
the founders of the field,
and thinkers in Black studies.
And I think a number of
us have been doing that.
And I'm thinking about the involvement
of major institutions,
like the Shakespeare
Association of America,
which has been a force of
transformation in the field
over the last couple of years.
So, I don't want to sound too naive here.
I think I'm in line with everybody here,
but I am very willing to be opportunistic
as far as disciplines are
concerned to make change happen.
But concerning the objects
versus subject difference,
perhaps I wasn't clear, I was
actually trying to suggest
that this involvement
of my field in building a pipeline
to diversify the professorate
means that we are very acutely,
painfully, acutely aware,
of the fact that we need new
subjects doing this work.
As I was mentioning, there are
less than 20 faculty members
who are Black Shakespeareans
in this country, right?
Every department, every,
every, every English major
is going to take a Shakespeare
course at some point.
20 professors are Black, doing this work.
So, we are very aware of it.
But to clarify what I meant
when I said new objects,
I don't mean that the objects
themselves are changing,
I mean that if you bring new
subjects to work on them,
they will see new things because
the way we read the world
is positioned and conditional
upon our own positionality, right?
So, if you get a scholar
like me, for instance,
who lives in a Black body
and is used to speaking with an accent,
then the question of the Black accents
in the early modern repertoire
is going to be something that they see
in plays that other scholars
had not seen before.
So, I think actually that the production
of new objects of
knowledge and new subjects,
those are actually completely
embedded, they work together.
And this is the only way, really,
to see new exciting things
about the figure of like
Shakespeare at this point.
- Marci, or Matt, or Rod,
any things emerge from this
that you want to weigh on?
Yeah, go ahead, Matt.
- I just wanna say what
Noemie and Teresa were saying
is so totally and devastatingly apparent
that if you don't diversify the faculty
at the same time that you
diversify the material we study,
you end up with the
story of the moo-h family
and the story of Penn and Princeton,
which is currently all over the news,
which is a repeat of the story
that Teresa started with,
the ways in which the pain
of minoritized subjects
becomes the object of
established disciplines,
is just too familiar
and can't be repeated.
- And I'll add that
this is social movement wisdom
in terms of the link
between the constitution
of the object
and the simultaneous
introduction of new subjects.
if you think about, for
instance, what Angela Davis says
in that documentary,
"Herbert's Hippopotamus"
about Herbert Marcuse at UC San Diego,
she's talking about the
Lumumba-Zapata Movement in 1969,
when the University says,
"We're gonna have a new college.
It's gonna be called Third College."
And she says, "No, my
comrades and I have decided
it will be called
Lumumba-Zapata College. (laughs)
It will not be called third college.
And we had a curriculum," right?
So, they took over the
college with the intention
of producing and introducing new subjects,
peoples, communities, into the college,
and they had a curriculum, right,
so that the introduction of
these folks necessarily meant
an epistemic shift,
that there had to be a new way
of understanding the world,
the U.S., race, colonialism,
the legacies of colonialism.
And we see that kinda thing
repeated, for instance,
at the Open Admissions
Movement at City College,
that the introduction, in that context,
of African-Americans and
Puerto Rican students,
anybody who wanted to be in
could get in, was the idea,
they also produced a new curriculum
and had a vision for a school,
the same thing for San Francisco State.
So, the link between the
constitution of epistemic objects
and the production of new subjects,
that's social movement wisdom.
- Yeah, yeah. Marci?
- So, you mentioned San
Francisco State, Rod.
Actually, I was doing some
work with an artist actually,
who has made work about the
Third World Liberation Front
and he pulled out an archival
document he had in his studio
'cause he was like
hanging out with everyone,
and one of the things on
the third world curriculum,
like in '68, was an
Asian-American art course.
And so, there's that.
But I just wanna say I agree
with what everyone has said,
of course, about new subjects
and new objects being kind of intertwined.
When I first drafted my talk,
my remarks were way too long,
but I had this story about like,
which I'm sure all of
us have similar stories,
which is like, like, in 2014,
so, this was like seven years ago,
and I know it was the state
because it was around
the time of Ferguson,
I went to someone on faculty
at the Institute of Fine Arts at NYU,
where I was getting my PhD in art history.
It's no one on my committee,
or not my advisor,
and told him I wanted to work on race
and Asian-American things.
And he told me that I
should work on Jewishness
because art historians are Jewish,
and so, they'll be more
sympathetic to my topic.
This is like seven years ago. (laughs)
And I think that all of the assumptions
about the relationship
of subjects and objects
is in that statement.
- Yeah, you say seven years ago,
much of that meant it was a long time ago
or it was just yesterday,
that's how horrible the thought is.
- I have no idea honestly, but-
- It almost feels like a 1958
kind of comment, yeah, yeah.
Time flies and then it
doesn't move at all.
- Yeah, yeah.
And so, it's just to say that
art history is so conservative
and has been for such a long time.
It's sometimes even really
hard to explain this
to my friends in English.
They were like there's a subfield
of Asian-American studies,
there's no Asian-American literature.
Some field doesn't exist in art history.
And I think the other thing
about like new objects and the pipeline,
something that Teresa mentioned as well,
it's like, I talk about this
with my friends of color
who are art historians, all the time,
and we're like, it's the privilege
of being able to work in
a museum over the summer
and get that hands-on
experience with objects,
which then gives you connections
to go into fellowships.
And so, academia is
actually really interleaved
with a lot of like kind
of funding organizations
that themselves still are,
yeah, like, are still
kinda guided by capital.
And so, there's a lot of
work to be done, still.
- Right, I mean, and this connects,
what you're saying,
Marci, to a broader issue,
I'm gonna just throw it out
there while it's on my mind,
but I do wanna start asking
some audience questions,
and there's a really
good one to start with,
but there's this realization
that the work that has
to be done is really,
the academic work is tethered
to structures of power
that our departments, disciplines,
and even some of our inter-disciplines,
reinforce through a sense of hierarchy
about what kinds of work
matters, how that work is done,
and who's going to evaluate
the value of that work.
And just, I mean, Noemie,
I agree that English
is a little more porous,
but I wouldn't say that the
level of creative integration
and complexity that you're doing
is pretty standard in English departments.
That's the problem with
gathering creative people
who are pushing all these boundaries
because they're like,
"Hey, yeah, look at us.
We're here." And I'm like, "Yeah."
And then there's like 40 million people
standing over there in the corner
in a straight disciplinary line.
So, anyway, I won't go back to that
because that's my pet peeve.
And this is a question for
anyone who wants to answer it,
but it's drawn on Matt's concept
and part of what he said.
So, I'm gonna read the question
and give you all a chance
to answer it, okay.
This person is asking the following.
"I'm moved by Doctor Guterl's call
for us to prepare for a reckoning
that stands to be cataclysmic
to the academy as we know it.
I wanna ask the Roundtable
what their knives
and their emergency packs are.
Given that this reckoning
is not just coming,
but for graduate students,
postdocs, and adjuncts
among us, it's already here,
what are the contingency
plans and alternative homes
for intellectual work that
we should be investing in?"
So, there are two questions there.
I will just ask that you take one
and that will just give us room
for other people to take another.
So, one is what are the
knives and emergency packs
to prepare for the reckoning
that stands to be
cataclysmic in the academy?
That's Question A, so, what's
your emergency pack/knife?
And the other is,
given that the reckoning
is basically here,
what are the contingency
plans and alternative homes
for intellectual work that
we should be investing in?
And this kind of dovetails
with what Rod was saying
about having your own curriculum, right,
and, as a possibility
now, where that might be,
you might have other locations.
But I will open the floor to
anyone who wants to pick up one
or the other of those questions.
- Well, I'm happy to get us started
with the second question, plan
Bs, what are some plan Bs?
I think the plan Bs are very compatible
with the plan As to start with.
But my point is that I am thinking,
every kind of work that will
allow the transformation
that we're trying to have happen
in the Plan A in the academy,
every single form of work
that will enable that to radiate, right?
For instance, we want
students to be, in my field,
already invested, having
some interest in working
in pre-modern race
studies, dealing with race,
and Shakespeare, and how
everything is working.
It's already too late, usually,
when they arrive in college level.
They already think that Shakespeare
and everything from that
time period is not for them.
So, actually, investing
heavily in the training
of our high school teachers
and giving them the tools
to do some of that work earlier
on when it's still possible,
that is really important.
I'm also thinking about the kind of work
that we see partner institutions doing,
for instance, again, I'm
thinking about what I know,
I'm thinking about the
institutions that I'm working with,
I'm thinking of the Newberry
Library, for instance,
which is, at the moment, really invested
in early modern critical race studies,
and is trying to help
make that work visible.
So, in 2023 RaceB4Race
is coming to Chicago.
The Newberry Library is
curating an exhibition
that will be opened to everybody,
to the Republic, and to
high school students,
in order to familiarize
folks with those questions.
There are jobs there, there
are forms of expertise
that we are trained to provide,
that we are trained to
give to our own students
that were graduate students,
and that we don't have the time
or the bandwidth to share with everybody.
So, involving the excellent students
that we train into that work
so that they might be able
to share that knowledge
as their contingency plan,
I think, is something that
should be on the table.
- Hmm, very helpful.
Excellent way to get us going.
Anybody else wanna jump in on Plan B
or other intellectual work
preparing for the reckoning,
contingency, alternative home?
- Well, I'll just add a little
bit to what you were saying
since I'm also in Chicago
and I am doing projects
with Newberry right now.
I think a lot of my public
scholarship, as I said,
I started in museum studies
and even though I didn't
go the full curation route,
I've maintained a foot in that world
because of its importance
for public education,
because of the failure to prepare students
having any sort of
understanding of Native history,
usually in their K-through-12 education.
And then once I get freshmen
or sophomore students,
and having to really start
from the very beginning
with Native history before I can even get
into more complicated
ideas around sovereignty,
or land status, or blood quantum,
I think one way to do
that is through museums,
because this is a place that
a lot of students will go,
and that is their first introduction
to what Native people are.
As somebody who also got my degree at NYU,
I'd go to the American
museum of natural history,
and it's appalling, as most
museums of natural history are,
and you literally have all of
the other people of the world,
you have the Indigenous
people, you have Africans,
you have everyone that is not White,
in a museum on display next to-
- Bear.
- Wooly mammoths. (chuckles)
So, it's part of this
continuum and hierarchy
that, I think,
children begin to
understand and naturalize.
With that being said, so, the
field museum here in Chicago
also has a really bad history.
Its earliest collections are
through the 1893 World's Fair.
And they also, until recently,
had old Native-American displays.
But for the past two years,
the institution has
undertaken this new initiative
to redesign their
Native-American galleries
and to invite Native scholars, curators,
to help with this new formation.
So, I was invited to be a guest curator
on some of the cases,
and I've been working on
this for the past year,
and this has really,
there's been some challenges
along the way, I won't lie,
but having the opportunity to
actually help guide the voice
and interpretation of what
is going to be on display now
for the next however it does in 20 years,
like, that to me, is
possibly more impactful
than any like journal article
that I'm writing right now,
in terms of audience reach.
And those sorts of things
aren't necessarily the first thing
that one considers for their tenure file.
But for me, what's important
is having my scholarship reach places
that's not behind a paywall.
So, just building off of
what all of you were saying
is, like, these are like tangible ways
that we can try to shift discourses
and to educate people in ways
that perhaps aren't necessarily
the traditional ways
that we've been taught.
So, yeah, I think museum institutions
is one way to go about that change.
- [Tricia] Thank you.
- I can jump in.
So, for me, this answer,
like, A and B are related.
This past year, I have a lot of friends
who are faculty members of
color, especially junior faculty,
and I don't think I've talked
to a single one of them
without the topic of leaving
the academy coming up.
I think all of us are
just like, "What do we do?
And how is our labor being used?"
And actually, that might be the answer,
which is, not necessarily leaving,
but being willing to leave.
And realizing that,
well, I mean, one, being in
conversation with people,
so, being in community with people
who are engaging with similar things,
but two, like, I'd say like
my toolkit is psychoanalysis,
because I've really had to
think very hard this year
about my own attachments,
my continued attachments to Whiteness,
like structures of Whiteness
and structures of legitimacy,
and, of course, that work is
forever incomplete, right?
But I really think that
thinking about my own attachments
and being willing to see
outside of the structure
and realize that, like,
I am a whole person without it,
is, to me, the first
step in trying to rethink
what I need to rethink.
- I think there have to be
a number of different ways
to approach this, and I think we need
all of these kinds of modes.
I, for one, Tricia, you
know as well as I do
that giving up on the institution,
all of us giving up on
the institution at once
would be destructive
and catastrophic in the
ways that I'm describing.
And in fact, higher education
is one of the least innovative industries
or business models.
If you think about it,
we've seen very few new
university startups,
and it's amazing how
durable these brands are
and how resistant they are to destruction.
We haven't seen the university collapses
that we thought we were gonna see
at the start of this pandemic,
and we're not likely to.
So, one thing I would suggest
is that new ways of thinking
about the institution
could be materialized in front of us.
And one exit strategy for us
all would be to think about
whether the brands we attach ourselves to,
Brown, Yale, University
of Chicago, and Stanford,
are the brands we wanna be attached to,
whether we wanna be attached
to a different kind of community
and a different kind of institution
that we might make anew.
At the same time, like, I also
know that, like, sometimes
the difference between
hiring a person at Brown
is the difference between one last email
in the middle of the night,
one last cup of coffee,
one last meeting with
the Dean, one last try,
and you can't stop that, right?
So, as a senior faculty
member, I can't stop that labor
because that could be the difference
between the right person getting the job
and the wrong person getting the job.
- Right, and that could have
a 40-year catastrophic impact.
Yeah, sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt,
I just I couldn't help
but then draw out the consequences, right?
- My kid is definitely
gonna have coffee and candy
for sort of late night emails, and.
- Yeah, your kids are lucky
that you're so disciplined.
They get treat.
Rod, did you wanna jump in here?
- Well, let's see.
Maybe I'll have some fun with A,
what would I bring with me?
Honestly, I would bring with me
a pen and a paper, and a big
note board for the students.
One of the reasons I love that
passage from Derrida is that,
in addition to saying that the
imagining of the institution,
or the re-imagining of the
institution is immediate
to what we do, it's also very simple.
It means that, okay, let me start writing,
or let me start crafting this course.
And in that moment,
a new socius, a new community,
can be brought into being.
So, I mean, at the end of the day,
I joke with my students sometimes,
being from rural Georgia and
having very good Black teachers
who were veterans of segregated teaching,
that at the end of the day,
I am that old Negro intellectual.
You give me a pen and a paper,
let me teach, let me write,
and I can do something.
- Yeah, yeah, give me the material.
- Just give me the material,
and let me do my job,
and something's gonna happen.
- Right, right.
So, I mean, that's interesting because
a lot of your comments as
a panel were a combination
of sort of taking a certain
kind of for granted-ness
of what Rod just emphasized,
which is that you're
bringing to these objects,
bringing to these museums,
bringing to various departments,
bringing to visual
culture, and art history,
a whole set of framework.
So, a tradition of critique,
a tradition of transformation and refusal
that is part of a process.
I just wanna put that on the extra.
I mean, Rod was just saying,
you know where I'm coming
from, just give me some paper,
but the paper has to be
in the right hands, right,
the paper and the pen.
And so, all of you are
actually articulating this.
And in that sense, I'd say
the knives and emergency packs
are not literal, right,
they're really the way we do what we do,
not the object that we do it with.
So, whether it's a knife
or an emergency pack,
it doesn't actually
matter, it's really about
the form of intensive critique
and refusal, to some degree.
So, before we close, I
just wanna give you all
an opportunity, first of all,
to ask each other any questions,
to talk them about things that
I unfortunately stepped over
that I shouldn't have, or things
that have come to your mind
that you wanna leave us with
in the form of closing comments,
'cause by the time we
get to you all speaking,
it'll probably be a little bit past 4:30.
So, I'm just gonna leave the floor open.
And if you don't have anything
other than closing comments,
just offer some closing comments
about how we can really pursue
this kind of intervention
that we want to see.
- Can I make a quick comment,
getting back to something
Matt said earlier,
when you were talking, Matt,
about the English discipline
and the fact that it's been
limited by its inability
to shed stupid periodization
or division on the basis of language,
which I resent very deeply?
So, I'm on board with you there.
But you also mentioned
something very interesting,
which is that medieval
studies, in particular,
have become, the knowledge,
the extraordinary body of knowledge
that's been produced over
decades in medieval studies
has suddenly become the bedrock
of a lot of White supremacist
propaganda these days.
Absolutely true.
I just wanna point out that
we're fighting back, right,
we're fighting back.
And RaceB4Race, I'll keep mentioning it,
was based upon the idea of
bringing together medievalists
who don't yet have a very strong tradition
of working with critical race theory,
bringing them together
with early modernists
who have been doing that since the '90s,
and the next iteration
of the conference at Brandeis next week
is going to actually bring in classists.
So, we're going back further and further
dealing with RaceB4Race.
But the idea is that precisely
we can not let that happen.
We can not let all the cultural artifacts
produced during those time periods
become fodder for that nonsense.
And so, that, I think,
is what actually makes
our work meaningful.
- Yeah. Let me say two quick things.
Can you repeat the Brandeis conference
because there were people
asking about it in the chat
and I didn't wanna interrupt?
So, or if you could put it in the chat.
- I think I dropped the link
earlier, but I will redo it,
I will drop the link in the chat again.
It's RaceB4Race at Brandeis University.
It starts next week.
- Great, great. Yeah.
And just to really comment
on the so important observation you made
that we think of social
justice and racial intervention
being the beginning of a conversation
about racial intervention,
when in fact, the disciplines
as colonial forms of ideology formation
were all actually the first
racial interventionists, right,
and they're coming back strong.
But anyway, I'll leave that alone.
But I just thought that
was super important.
Anybody else in closing
or any other thoughts?
- I was just gonna say
to Noemie's comments,
I remember how thrilling it was
when I was an undergraduate
at Howard in 1990
to discover that folks like Martin Bernal
were intervening in the field of classics.
And then later on, when
I was a grad student
at UC San Diego,
taking a course,
a feminist theory
course, with Paige DuBois
and her interventions
via Marxism and feminism,
and post-colonial studies, and
psychoanalysis in classics,
and just seeing the ways in which,
both at Howard and at UCSD's
literature department,
that those interventions became the sites
for the introduction of
new feminist subjects,
new Black subjects in those fields,
it was really, really an
exciting thing to witness,
and also to repeat.
- I mean, I would wanna return
to one of the things I
said in my opening remarks,
which is that, in a way,
I really do feel enveloped
in such an abundance of interesting work,
interesting, relevant, just
and righteous work on race
that falls within the humanities,
in a way that I didn't feel
when I was a graduate student,
that the sheer volume of
material that lands on my desk
or arrives on my computer screen,
or shows up on my television,
is just extraordinary.
This is worth fighting for,
and it's worth trying to center
to take all of that material,
worth trying to center
in these medieval
institutions we inhabit here.
So, I want us to sort
of think about the ways
in which we can bring all
of that joyful abundance
and put it at the center of these places,
again, even if that means
breaking them a little bit, or a lot.
- Yeah, yeah, excellent. Thank you.
Teresa, or Marci, or,
any closing thoughts?
- Yeah, I guess, maybe just that
every single time I return to
one of the works of art that
I've been really spent
my time at Stanford looking at,
it always exceeds
the capacity of any single
discourse to capture it.
- All right. Teresa.
- Well, I just wanna say thank you
to everyone for having me here.
I wanna give a shout out
to my colleague at U
Chicago, Sarah Johnson.
We were actually awarded
some Mellon funding
for the next academic year.
So, we're gonna be starting this project
called "Tracing Relations:
Blackness and Indigeneity
in the Americas".
And this is inspired by,
she's in English and Black Studies,
and I'm coming from
Anthropology and Native Studies,
and I think both of us
have come to the space
of vulnerability together.
There's so much that I have yet to learn
in reading of Black studies
as someone who's mostly been
reading in Native studies,
and her, vice versa.
So, for anyone from U
Chicago who's watching,
just be on the lookout
'cause we're gonna be
having reading groups
and film screenings next year,
convened around this orienting
theme of relationality
that we find really important
to both of those
disciplines and discourses.
But I feel like some of the discussions
we've been having today
has actually given me a lot of new ideas
for how we can move forward on that.
We do plan to make a website for this,
and maybe we'll have
some virtual component
that we can continue with
the same group of people,
but we don't have that yet.
So, I just wanna say thank you
for giving me the opportunity
to think further on this project.
- Yes, yes, indeed.
And even I feel the same way,
and I'm sure my Director,
colleagues, Jennifer,
and O'Riley, and Steve,
and I'm I missing anybody,
no, it's four of us,
I always have to count
one, two, three, four.
I've been super inspired by
listening to all of you here,
really thinks in such rich
ways about the problem,
the solutions, the impossibilities,
the places to both hide
out and to be visible,
and the role of just
such creative thinking,
which, I think, has
been so important here.
So, I'm really inspired,
and I'm hoping our grant
will benefit from and take
out a number of the things
that we've been doing here.
So, thank you so much, all of you,
for being a part of this inaugural,
what we hope may be an annual conference
on racial reckoning,
'cause we wanna keep opening up the space.
Let us know what you're
working on, stay in touch.
And thank those of you who
showed up in the audience
and asked great questions,
and hung out with us this afternoon.
And we will see you again.
There's an event tomorrow
at the same time.
I believe it's the same link for sign up,
but I'm sure you can find
that how you found this,
and maybe I'll put it in the chat.
So, thank you all very much for coming,
and thanks again to the fine panelists
for being really terrific.
Thanks very much, everybody. Good night.